a orillas del mar arábigo se extiende
carache la megalópolis tiene 17 millones
de habitantes eso es de 30 veces más que
hace 60 años una urbanización galopante
que ha dado lugar a decenas de miles de
construcciones insalubres y no reguladas
como aquí donde el colapso de un
edificio cobró la vida de 22
paquistaníes el verano pasado ali
cuchillo vive en uno de esos edificios
esta es mi casa miren lo oscuro que está
no hay luz aquí no hay agua está muy
sucia seis personas viven en esta
habitación
esta es la cocina no hay ningún sistema
de agua aquí tenemos que lavar los
platos en la acera vinimos aquí porque
el propietario no nos pidió el alquiler
por adelantado nos enteramos de que el
edificio se había construido sin permiso
después de un mes cuando los
funcionarios municipales vinieron a
explicar no podemos hacer nada contra
esta mafia el gobierno y otras personas
poderosas los apoyan o corrompen a todo
el mundo nos tienen del cuello porque
somos pobres
thomas burgess tem
y es que me quiero irme de este lugar lo
antes posible
nic ajaw yo que tengo miedo día y noche
desde que el edificio de al lado se
derrama
wei la construcción la recolección de
basura y el suministro de agua tres
áreas muy buenas para la corrupción y el
crimen organizado en karachi
la estación de agua potable está bajo la
jurisdicción del municipio como los
sistemas de tuberías son obsoletos el
precioso líquido solo se distribuye en
la mitad de la ciudad así que el estado
contrata el suministro a estos camiones
que venden el agua a 3 o 5 veces el
precio de compra
en la mayoría de los barrios no hay agua
gran parte del agua es robada por
personas que instalan conexiones
ilegales mis empleadores ganan mucho
dinero en este negocio es algo injusto
para mí porque la mayoría de la gente a
la que se lo vendemos es pobre
en la colonia marchar el distrito de los
mosquitos el agua es un bien escaso
distribuidos solo en ciertos puntos
[Aplausos]
las mujeres se encargan del
abastecimiento mientras sus maridos
trabajan pregúntele a quien quiera
nuestro barrio está seco cada familia
gasta una gran parte de su salario en
agua y nuestras familias son muchas es
difícil llevar este bidón de agua y mis
hijos van a trabajar durante el día así
que siempre llevo un bidón de agua
no estoy aquí por caridad que el agua es
gratis para ti son 30 rupias toma tu
botella de té
aunque nos roben estos vendedores son
una bendición para nosotros sin ellos
este lugar se habría convertido en un
desierto hay 500.000 personas en este
lado de la ciudad y aún así no pasan por
aquí las tuberías de la ciudad eduardo
la liga line
esta escasez ha fomentado el desarrollo
de una mafia del agua que ha
multiplicado las estaciones de bombeo
ilegales sus bombas extraen directamente
de las capas freáticas que ya están muy
secas en karachi o se están conectando a
los conductos subterráneos de la ciudad
como aquí donde el sistema de bombeo
está instalado dentro de una casa aquí
enciendo el mecánico entonces el agua
entra a este gran depósito desde allí la
bombeamos a los camiones cisterna de
afuera
solucionamos de 10 a 12 escalones
sistemas al día eso es todo porque puede
ejecutar la policía en los últimos tres
años la policía ha llevado a cabo más de
200 redadas para neutralizar estas
instalaciones en vano demasiados
funcionarios son corruptos como nos
explica este policía de campo que por
miedo a las represalias desea permanecer
en el anonimato
si la policía local así lo deseara
podría cerrar esas bocas de riego en 10
minutos pero hay demasiados sobornos una
vez mis colegas y yo dirigimos una
campaña de represión a nuestro vehículo
iba hacia las instalaciones pero la
banda nos vio venir así que nos chocaron
con un gran camión cisterna y nos
golpearon tuvimos que saltar del
vehículo y correr para salvar nuestras
vidas incluso en los barrios acomodados
de la ciudad el agua es escasa los
ductos que existen llevan agua te rosa y
salada
la geógrafa símica mal se ve obligada a
transportar el agua en un camión sea
tengo que llamar a la mafia de
los camiones externos en alguna de las
investigaciones que hemos hecho sobre el
tema
he tenido que tratar con gente armada
pero porque hay una mafia la mafia está
aquí porque se lo permitimos hemos
frenado la ecología de la ciudad
acaparando muy rápidamente la tierra y
construyendo edificios pesados en ella
estas malas prácticas agravan una
situación ya muy preocupante debido al
calentamiento global el éxodo rural
continua es una gran oportunidad para
las mafias de crímenes ambientales en
karachi